c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche team blond c'est boutora
sera enfin ça dépend
basset d'astreinte ça passera régime
c'est l'enfer on n'en peut plus tout
n'avions d'origine d'astra parce que ça
peut être rigolo c'est divertissant ne
faut pas le prendre au sérieux pour
qu'un très bon dj madame d'un train le
métro parce que ça peut être race ras
pour la chaleur et les odeurs mais
s'appelle d'arc à trop les rencontres
c'est pas un site de rencontre c'est
ainsi de 5,1 trucks expectra nos poils
et vert
marca enfin date rap parce que j'aime
faire enlever bientôt donc au mieux
réfléchir d'arcade à tous les niveaux
ratera je regrette beaucoup ça abîme
trop la peau totalement rastkhah nonda
sera un petit peu race ram et un bon
côté dark à col rond sera totale j'ai
fait une crise angoisse quand j'ai été
voir ça ce sera mon dernier film
d'horreur
[Musique]